so your book calls this chapter
Calvinism and the reformed tradition and
if I were to like pick out a difference
heading for it I would do this it's a
Calvinism and then I put in parenthesis
a couple of things you got the reform so
like in for example around here in New
York that's reformed on time actually
important denomination because there
were a lot of Dutch people here and they
tended to be reformed but there's other
people that fit within this spectrum at
all as well they would include what we
call Presbyterians and then when had
pointed out before the Puritans the
Puritans were very important in England
for a while like I said they actually
took over the English state and had
their own government in place under
Oliver Cromwell who was a Puritan didn't
last very long and it was incredibly
unpopular reasons you can probably guess
and a lot of the Pearson's came to the
what's nowadays you know Massachusetts
Maine Connecticut some of the other
areas around there so here we're talking
about when we put this term up what
would a religious history we call the
radical Reformation what is this term
radical mean let's turn until I got a
thing for surfers to say good that's not
the real meaning of it yeah Mary or out
of the ordinary that's another meeting
that we associated with it now if
somebody's you know a radical you know
far writer far laughter
you know there's our way out of the
mainstream and you know to a certain
extent these get were out of the
mainstream if you compare to the
Lutheran's and Catholics hey so yeah
like extreme that would be along the
same lines is that now why would
somebody be extremely just just to be a
jerk yeah you're right and that goes
along with being extreme you're going to
you know you're extremely precisely
because you want significant changes
there's different ways of doing changes
all right let me sort of take a
different no glad political signs that
you want to change something for the
news revolutionary you want to change it
to go back to the oldest radical that's
usually reactionary usually radical is
changing it for the new and that's a
sort of derivative term as well did you
whoever told you that it was going back
to the old is getting closer to the
older sense of the term though radical
needs to go back to roots radics means
root and laugh now a lot of radicals
ended up because the meetings has
changed right so now if people want to
like totally change things and all that
what were the routes that these guys
wanted to go back to well for John
Calvin it was the Bible and as opposed
to the Lutheran's or the Anglicans who
are willing to hold on to a lot of
elements of cap of practice and dotted
and they said well the things that need
to be changed let's change them Catholic
with Kelvin it was sort of burden field
and replant it and the only things that
can be legitimate must have some sort of
warrant coming from the Bible so your
book has all sorts of contrasts between
Luther and Calvin
and a lot of them stem from this this is
emphasis on biblical warrant for any
sort of practice if it's not in the
Bible then you shouldn't do it it
shouldn't be part of your practice part
of your beliefs so anything like
tradition would have to go by the
wayside whereas her Anglican tradition
is actually part of you know their way
of doing then Lou Therans hold on to a
lot of tradition Calvinists are getting
rid of so he's got some you know some
examples of this like music had to be
confined to songs found in the Bible
itself what did one of most of the songs
of the Bible what's the one book where
you got most of them yeah the Psalms so
that's pretty restrictive you know
Luther was making up his own songs you
wouldn't find Calvinists singing luther
songs let alone older you know catholic
music places that the complex and formal
liturgy that Luther adopted from Latin
into German was abandoned in favor of a
simple order of career psalm-singing and
especially preaching sacraments and
there were different understandings of
the nature of sacrament in the reformed
tradition sacraments would not be
celebrated very often and in fact end up
being seen as not not the real presence
of spiritual presence a symbolic
presence calvin is kind of you know and
odds with most of the other people in
this tradition when it comes to that
another thing that's really central to
its calvin like your book says is Luther
was concerned with justification calvin
was very concerned with predestination
this is this view
predestination notion that God has
decided who was saved from from all time
so if we were Calvinists in this sense
let's say we were a dick you know
Calvinist congregation hopefully all of
us are actually saved and if we're saved
it's not through anything we did as a
matter of fact some will go so far as to
say if you're saying you can't actually
lose that salvation because you'd be
forcing God's hand and all those other
people out there there's fruit there
there damn there's nothing they can do
you know the signs that you're saved or
that you're here in church and that
you're living a godly life and that
things seem to be going well for you but
even then you might actually be you know
a hypocrite and you're just going to
hide it you guys ever read like the
scarlet letter yeah that's a Puritan
novel right and that's coming out of
this notion you know the minister is
very upset with himself because he's
actually done some things that a safe
person wouldn't do so he thinks that
he's probably damned you know yeah how's
that different then know that Luke
current like Luther his idea was that I
only got contract original sentence yeah
so like its salvation can't be achieved
through hang and effort yeah Luther is
saying what the stuffs there for the
Gospels there for you you know God is
giving you the grace that you need you
if you throw it away that's your fault
whereas if you take this far you can
actually say you know it's not really
their fault that the damned some people
just never get a shot there's various
interpretation
your book talks about in terms of
emphasis you know with Calvin this is
front and center Luther you know he he's
not quite so clear it up it's a good
question this is probably actually a
good place to bring in something else
your book talks about which was this guy
lack of our minions who's taking a much
stronger opposition and he was he was a
Calvinist who said I don't actually
think this predestination thing as a
warrant in Scripture I think we actually
do have some sort of role God does give
us the grace that we would need in order
to them he's saved with you know the
things that we do so one of the key
opposition's in the not in the reformed
tradition but for say Baptists who will
look at a little bit later would be
between Calvinism and arminianism so I
just want to quick that out we won't we
won't go any further into that because
there's other things we want to look at
with this calculus see the human being
as you might say radically damaged by
original sin you could depending on how
you look at st. Augustine you could say
they're the most faithful followers of
Augustine or that they august Dean
Augustine himself and go way further
than he intended with his notion of
original sin but that's part of why you
know for Calvin's human beings can
really can't do anything when it comes
to their own salvation there's this
discussion of the tulip thing and you
notice that that some of these have to
do with consequences of predestination
like the limited atonement atonement in
theological terms is is the sacrifice
that Christ is making for other people
right so that people are saved that's
the traditional theology and and most of
the churches would say christ died for
everybody not everybody uses that but
you know in theory it's there for
everybody even the non-christians
Calvinists would say no that doesn't
make sense
if you believe in predestination he
didn't die for everybody he only died
for the people who are actually saved
they were following through our logic of
this inexorably now a few other things
that are really distinctive about it we
talked about the sacraments we talked
about ah this is that I knew we had
something very important on your book
talks about church polity and they had
another term that you probably aren't
used to do they use this term at all in
political science these days holiday
together right across seven think so
things it means something like
organization on organization and
structure who should be in charge how do
you make decisions all those sorts of
things so you know by contrast think of
the Catholic Church who's ultimately
like the decider at the top of the
pyramid of hope right so that's part of
the polity and that under the Pope we
have booths remember right the bishops
and then bishops are in charge of all
the people in the diocese but especially
the guys who do the the priests and then
the priests are supposed to be you know
a ministering to the lady that's a no
that's an organization right that's a
way of structuring things that's a
holiday in the reformed tradition
there's two models that are available
the Puritans had one model the
congregational model which means that
the congregation itself is the group and
they covenant with each other to it's
very democratic in many ways they
covenant with each other to be part of
that that community for the rest of the
reformed it was we saw Presbyterian
structure yeah I'm willing to bet that
doesn't mean that word doesn't mean very
much to you we're talking about who
should be in charge press matter it's a
Greek word that is used a lot in
Scripture and it can mean one of two
things it can mean elder whole you know
an older person or again mean priest and
the reformed tradition they they
interpret it as uniformly beating elder
so somebody who is an elder somebody who
holds power within the community and
they're the ones who decide about church
discipline who should for example who is
actually worthy to take the sacraments
or not they would actually decide well
you get to go to communion you don't get
to go to communion when they would do it
you know the times of the year that they
would hold of the service the elders are
the ones who are actually in charge the
minister is just sort of their their
employee a lot of respects they get to
pick that who do you think that decides
to the elders are going to be
how would you how would you do that if
you already have some elders in place if
you have an election every year older
election can see or not is this thing in
the way okay yeah um would like the
existing elders take the new one exactly
yeah because they're the ones who are in
charge so it's a you can think of it as
a self-perpetuating class of people who
are are charged with making sure that
everything goes the way they're not to
go it would be like if if you had
members of Congress and instead of
voting for them they voted for the Pooh
the next members of Congress are gonna
see how that would how that would work
and that's the way the church tends to
be structured for reformed and for
Presbyterian Presbyterian it's right
there in the word what else do we need
to get a oh I need to tell you a little
bit about we're this wet your book
points out that Calvinism or the
reformed tradition really begins in one
area Geneva is very important where and
where is Geneva it's in Switzerland and
Switzerland at that time is a bunch of
more or less independent when they call
Canton's and it's a pretty safe place to
be if you're somebody that the you know
the authorities are looking for because
it's a mountain territory and Calvin
gets me and all the people of Geneva
they actually like this is this is the
going concern this is the way of living
the Christian religion so they're not
going to turn him over Calvin was
actually fresh and Calvin wrote in Latin
and in French Calvinism spreads
throughout France yeah it actually led
to some civil wars in france between the
caf
and the Calvinist who were called the
Huguenots some of them came here to this
this very area if you go to New Paltz
you'll find you cannot street because a
lot of them left France at one time or
another and came to the places where it
was more hospitable to them the Dutch
were already reformed so New York was a
smart place for them to go it spread
into Germany as well so Germany was not
just Catholic or Lutheran very quickly
some of the Germans said we want to be
Calvin's we want to be reformed it's
ready and further east to hunger and to
bohemian and then it went up north this
is probably one of the most important
though there's two really important
effects of it we went to the Netherlands
to Holland and at that time the
Netherlands weren't independent they
were their own by the Spanish Spanish
king the Spaniards were Catholic and to
be against the the Spanish occupation it
made a lot of sense to embrace a way of
looking at Christianity that was very
different than that that seemed a lot
more democratic than the top-down
hierarchical model and so a lot of the
Dutch became reformed and the
Netherlands became a hotbed for the
reformed the last place that was really
important that this this way of
approaching Christian you went to it was
Scotland the presbytery ends are the
product of Calvinism going to Scotland
and this guy John Knox is the second
more most important John in the reformed
tradition after John Calvin John Knox
sort of leads this this movement and
what ends up happening notice where
burrs the reformed tradition gone too
it's gone too
toulon France Germany the Netherlands
some of the other you know further east
territories Scotland you've got all
these people they're all part of one big
network they write back and forth
there's there's lines of communication
it takes on a kind of international
character you know why there aren't any
French Huguenots left today it's this is
the part of that international character
it's because they mostly became Dutch
Reformed because nationality didn't
matter quite so much within the reformed
tradition the way that it did with an
Anglican tradition or within the
Lutheran tradition this is a like I said
this is a much more radical way of
reforming what they thought needed to be
changed within Christianity than the
Anglican of the Lutheran processes and
this is the third great branch of the
Reformation we get the the
Congregationalists churches from them
united church of christ by the way you
would never guess it from their current
theology because they definitely don't
you know by into predestination or stuff
like that they're the product of a lot
of these churches coming together in the
early 20th century the Presbyterians
that are still out there the Dutch
Reformed Hungarian reformed those are
the people who belong to this spectrum
they had an incredible influence outside
of the reform movement itself on the
Baptist's who are going to be a major
player in some of the later chapters up
and looking at so again this is one of
those sort of things today has been a
whole bunch of lectures about putting
things in your pocket that you're going
to pull out later on so you know who
these these players are sort of like I'm
giving you some some playing cards you
know there are some sports cards you
know when really mentally have the stats
you have the little narrative the
history
so that when we start talking about the
role that the Presbyterians played in
high arc and revolution or the fact that
the anglican meili became Tories and
they were on the wrong side of the
American Revolution and that have a
sufferer reprisals you'll understand why
that took place without having this
theological background a lot of the
pieces of the puzzle don't make an awful
lot of sense